[Music]  hey you kids it's dinner time  dinnertime my favorite nighttime  why does nobody come in through the  front door dearest mother and father we  will not be attending this evening's  ritual mastication  what they're both growing up so fast  they wouldn't be caught  dead with their parents  wait a minute what i've got a dish  it's kittious it's monstrous  it's the old adam's camper  time for some family bonding what huh  we are going on a road trip this is  cruel  even for you  [Applause]  this trip will bring the atoms closer  than ever before  let's make some memories  [Music]  it's just us and the wonderful sound of  silence  [Music]  now that's great  [Music]  good to see you my b whisker cousin  i still don't understand the word that  guy say  [Music]  where's kitty he and it hit the catnip  pretty hard last night